uncharted for hasn't been out for very
long but if you're working on that
platinum trophy you'll be happy to know
that Sony has a little extra prize for
achieving that goal I'm Tony and this
GameSpot news update is all about Nathan
Drake as discovered by reddit user
unique - earning uncharted fours
platinum trophy gets you a special email
from Sony and in that email is some nice
congratulatory artwork featuring the
game's cast it's not quite as big a
prize as the bloodborne Platinum theme
for ps4 but it's still a nice gesture
and if you manage to track down all of
Uncharted forest treasures beat the game
on crushing difficulty and do all the
other tasks that win you the platinum
it's nice to know that Sony will notice
uncharted 4 is off to a strong start
selling nearly 3 million copies in its
first week that's a lot of potential
emails being sent out some reddit users
are reporting that they never received
said email but hey Uncharted is all
about the journey not the destination
right and for all the best video game
journeys you're already in the right
place